esta ciudad de Torres en la provincia de
dones que en el don vas ha sido una de
esas ciudades que quedó en la línea de
batalla en la división desde que comenzó
la guerra en Ucrania que recordemos que
no fue el 24 de febrero sino en el 2014
cuando los grupos separatistas del Don
vast ya peleaban aquí con las tropas
ucranianas Así que aquí se creó una
primera línea de batalla muy pocos
metros de aquí Aunque ellos dicen que
durante estos últimos ocho años habían
aprendido a vivir con esta guerra y bajo
la normalidad pero todo se aceleró el 24
de febrero mayor batalla mayor presencia
de militares sin embargo también dicen
que poco a poco aprendieron a vivir
hasta los dos últimos meses cuando la
batalla realmente se recrudeció Ellos
dicen que alcanzaron a cerrar durante
tres frentes temían de que la ciudad
fuera rodeada y aislada por las tropas
rusas sin embargo los militares
desplegados a este lugar lograron
replegarlos y detener este avance y hoy
estas tropas han retrocedido otra vez a
enfocarse en la batalla por la ciudad de
bacmut Sin embargo ellos también
aseguran que es cada vez la vida es más
difícil y menos población en la ciudad
dicen que no más del 15% de la población
original no solamente por la batalla
sino por las condiciones de vida que no
hay gas no hay agua no hay electricidad
como en el resto de Ucrania y obviamente
temen que este invierno vaya a ser
muchísimo más difícil ayer Solo dos
misiles caían en el mercado local aunque
dicen que Afortunadamente no hubo
víctimas